こんにちは、
広野夫婦です。
今日は、
私たちが作成しているもの
と探しているものについてお話したいと思います。私たちは
毎日何かを作成しています。
音楽、
フード アーキテクチャ
製品、
または
コーディング
システムを作成し
続けています。何かを作成することを決して止めませ
ん。 やめる
私たちは常に動機と好奇心を持っています
なぜそれはそれで
始めましょう
私たちが得た非常に基本的な創造物を見てみましょう
そして
私たちが探しているもの
と基本を見てみましょう
例えば
料理をしますか
私は
年に一度、
月に一度料理します
そして
クロール はい、ファッション 今はファッション
と住む場所
私たちはそれを愛し、
次に
私たちは
交通機関システムを輸送し、
世界に挨拶します
国から国へ
新しいスタイルと新しいコミュニケーションの
相互作用が起こりました
すべてのドレスを見る
中華料理 日本料理 フレンチ
いっぱい
イタリア料理も、
それらのファッション、衣料品、
そして次に、
テレビ、
音楽、映画、
ドラマ、アニメ、
そして放送局も手に入れました スティングシステムにより、
ニュースを正しく見ることができます
ライブでニュースを見ることができます
リアルタイムで表示されます
今日の
デジタルテクノロジー
とインターネットラップトップ
スマートフォン
タブレット
インターネットを見ると
いつでもどこでも毎日すべての情報を取得でき、
何百万、何十億もの
情報を入手できます
あなたの作品のダウンロードをアップロードし続けています たぶんあなたが
欲しい情報 コース
のコンテンツ ドラマ 映画
エンターテイメント
とあなたは
物事の
例を得ることができます 陶器で作られた器を
作る方法
と調理方法を知っています
あなたが見ている オンラインで、
おそらくダンスも、
ここでは、
インターネットにアクセスするたびに、
ワンクリックですべての情報をすぐに取得できます。
サウンドとビジュアルを
一度の瞬間にすぐに取得できます。
これらのデジタルテクノロジー
と、ええと、インターネット
ネットワーク技術はそれを非常に速く認識しています
が、
私は何か違う、
またはそうではない何かをまだ
感じていますか？
ビジュアルとサウンドを表示できるので、これらすべてのインターネット テクノロジーに満足しています。
ビジュアル サウンドは素晴らしいです
が、
プロダクト デザインの世界で働いていたので、
これは
自分が望んでいたものとの間に一種のギャップがあると常に感じていましたが、
それを何とかしなければなりませんでした。
サウンド
とイマジネーションの
イメージです
が、私はこの素敵な暗
さを実際の 3D で手に入れました。ご存知のように
カット ドローイング
とモーション キャプチャ モデルを手に入れました。
それをみんなに見せたいのですが、
どうにかして音と画像に変換しなければなりません。
誰もがあなたの家のスマートフォンタブレットでそれを見ることができる
ので、
これがあなたの状況であることがわかります.
私の質問は、
なぜ
これら2つが
視覚的な
音だけなのか、なぜ
これら2つだけなのか、
私たちは視覚を持っているからです。
匂いを嗅いだり
触ったり
触覚や感覚を
持っているので、私たちは六感をすべて持っています
ところで、これは私が
得た感情のアイコンです。
これらの 6 つの感覚がある
ので、より多くの感覚を使用できるようにする必要があり、
デジタルに行進します。
視覚的な音をインターネットに接続します。
今、
私は 1 つの可能性を見つけ
ました。
3D モデルの 3D データを 3D 3D プリンターに送信して
3D プリントすると、実際
の
プラスチックやその他の素材を 8 時間で 3D モデルを
すぐに入手できます。
実際には30年間発明されましたが、
今ではデジタル技術
ソフトウェアインターネットを手に入れ、元の
オリジナルのアイデアをインターネットに送ることができ、
誰かがそれを編集し、
誰かがあなたのアイデアの価値から
リメイクしたり新しいモデルを作ったりすることができます。
プリンタ
だけど、
まだ2つの感覚は
視覚と触覚を見て、もう1つ
の感覚を追加するのは
面白いだろうので、
今回は視覚
と触覚を追加しました チンと
試食
ニュースでフード3Dプリンターまたはフードプリンターを聞いたことがありますか
クッキーを印刷できます チョコレートパスタ
ハンバーガーかもしれませんが、それでも
既存の
フード
パスタクッキーを模倣しています ああ、それはすべて存在していましたが、
フードプリンターが得て与えるものは、
実際にできるということです 編集してください。
ラップトップまたは
PC の mac でデジタル ペインティング ツールを使用したことがありますか。
実際にそれらのフレーバーのトマト パンを使用することができます。
また、
ステーキやケチャップ、マスタードを止めて、
これらのパレットに本物の味と本物の感覚を加えることができます。
そして、あなたは再びアヒルをデザインします
が、
実際にあなたのデザインのアヒルを食べることはできますが、
3Dプリンターについて話しているのではなく、
ファッションのクロールについて話している可能性があります。
他の人は、彼らが食べたランチの情報を得るかもしれませんし、
一人の女性はレストランから本当に素敵な食事をしました
ランチタイムに 1 人の男がとても素敵な 1 人を持っていた
ので、情報と本当の
味をすぐに共有する
か、握手をすることは
他の人とコミュニケーションをとる良い方法です。 今
でも本当に本物の味がします。
もっと
物理的な方法で説明しようとしているのは、
紙コップです。今日も紙コップを手に入れました。
ここで味覚ジェネレーターと名付けた味です。
紙コップを
つかんで、
たとえば、この女の子は
この味覚発生器を
口に持っていて、ちょうど
レストランのそばを通りかかったところ、レストランのデモの味を手に入れました。
これは、あなたが知っているどのレストランにも適用できるのは驚くべきことです。 デバイスが
通り過ぎるだけで、
通りを通り抜けるだけで、デモデモデモの味が得られ、
一度それを気に入ったら、それを試してみてください。
私は
自由に飛んでいる鳥にはならない
ので、視覚
と
ええと、
私が聞いて触覚で触れ、
また
感じることを追加するのはどうですか。
においセンサー
と今では、
ほぼ実際の方法でボードを取得できる
ので、そこに行く必要はありませんが、
そこに飛び出すことができます。ええと、
別の例を感じます。ええと、
ジャケットを持っています。私は
ジャケットを着ています。 内部に
触覚
テクスチャー
とテクスチャーの水を生成できるデバイスと缶がある
ので、
再びデジタルペインティングツールパレットのように選択します
タヒチの海を選択して、
ジャケットの内側にジャケットをドラッグし、椅子に寄りかかります そして
あなたは可能な限り海を感じます
ミキシングの最も強力なこと 私はデジタルとそれらの物質を融合させることを意味します あなたが
適用できるさまざまな素材を作ることができます あなたはさまざまな素材を適用することができます
別のオブジェクトに
トマトのフレーバー
ジャケット
おそらく香り もちろん、
味と香りの香りが混ざり合っている
可能性があります それは
2つの感覚の間の強力なつながりであり
、編集することができます これらのテクスチャをデザインできます
デジタルペインティングツールで色で何かをデザインする
か、すでに他の感覚を選択してください
私たちはコピー＆ペーストをすることができます
私たちはそれが大好きです
次に、
すべての感覚について何が
起こっているのか
想像できますか想像できます
か
その日、友人や家族と一緒に本当に素敵なレストランに行ったのですが、
味がとても良くて
本当に美味しかったことを覚えていますか 赤ちゃんのガールフレンドとの思い出に残る日
と初めての
夕食は、
実際にその時間を保存して、リアルに感じて
再生することも
できます。また、命を救う日記でもできます。
思い出の回想録をアーカイブし、
その日の例を 1 ページに示します。 本当に素敵な再会を得た
友達 ビーチでバレエと一緒に祈っている友達
素敵な気温 素敵なw  ind
で、私たちは事実上興奮しています。
保存できるので、再生してみませんか。
インターネット デジタル テクノロジーがあるので、
共有しませんか。
エルフのプライミングを経験したことはありません
が、マージを追加して
このテクノロジーを試すことができます。
これらすべての第六感を
想像できます
か いつの日か、
女性の心を理解して、なぜ
彼が私を平手打ちしたのかを理解することができます。
それをダウンロードして、
それを再生することができます。
あなたはそれを使っていません
次の創造のためにすべての感覚を使いましょう
ありがとう